[Musique]
le
benjamin bayart bonjour je vous
interviewez aujourd'hui pour un site
internet qui s'appelle singer view vous
aurions aimé avoir votre point de vue
sur des questions concernant de
l'amérique
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez vous dire sur
le cs ait ses nouveaux pouvoirs
d'abord il les a pas encore ses nouveaux
pouvoirs au moins une en train de se
tirer sur la nuit pour les obtenir ni
les a pas
dans le côté ça fait 18 ans que csa a
essayé d'avoir des pouvoirs sur le net
et qui n'ont pour le moment il n'y
arrive pas le gouvernement y est
favorable mais tous les gouvernements
depuis 18 ans y était favorable
c'est moins affolant que ça en a l'air
c'est inquiétant quand même parce que
c'est une source de problèmes et c'est
pour ça que ça fait 18 ans qu'on s'y
opposent
comprendre la question qui est au fond
il faut
en fait il faut voir ça de manière très
simple le pouvoir à une certaine le csa
certains pouvoirs une certaine
légitimité à réguler les contenus en
matière de perte tient pour des raisons
diane c'est faible non de gêne possible
envers siens ne pas y avoir 30 millions
de chaînes de télévision en france bat
sur lui retient pas sur les réseaux
anciens
c'est pour ça que le csa réguler c'est
pour ça que c'est ça un certain pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
comme ceux souvent expliqué dit que les
fréquences sont attribuées gratuitement
aux chaînes de télévision
c'est ça c'est plus c'est plus du tour
du radio amateur qui régule et les noms
mais d'ailleurs l'art divinatoire paris
ne sont pas régulés par le csa leur a
dit les radioamateurs c'est des
attributions de fréquences par l'arcep
qui ne fait que de la technique qui peut
jamais tout à fait le csa fait dieu fait
de la régulation de contenu parce qu'il
n'y a pas beaucoup de fréquences et
qu'elles sont attribués gratuitement
deux chaînes et le cs 1 pour ne pas
disparaître aimerait faire de la
régulation des contenus sur internet
c'est ça le fond de la question et
régulation de contenus sur internet il
n'y a pas de bonnes raisons de le faire
c'est aussi simple que ça le csa fait de
la régulation de conclure la télé parce
que ya pas assez de fréquences on ne
peut pas faire de la régulation des
contenus sur internet donc pour les
mêmes raisons parce que ya cette
fréquence on peut ouvrir un nombre
quelconque de chaînes de télévision et
sites web sur internet
et c'est la clé de voûte comprendre
l'enjeu est là après comprendre tout ce
que le csa pourra faire comme cogner sur
internet
et sont bornés à
la labellisation est un début c'est
facile c'est son nom sans impact majeur
et de médias
c'est un problème quand même selon
quelle morale le csa va labelliser quoi
si vous décidez donc il faut pas montrer
aux enfants donc si la morale change
qu'est ce qu'on fait
évidemment elle chance c'est une
question qui est compliqué j'ai encore
les plans des sages cause pour pouvoir
on aura un état fasciste point vous faut
faire avec
pour moi c'est justement parce qu'on
donne trop de pouvoir les endroits où il
doit pas y en avoir que
le mode de gouvernement change sa faut
pas se demander que fera le prochain
nazis au pouvoir avec les outils sont
dus à fès cette sauce demander en quoi
des outils conseils nous prépare un état
totalitaire de très bien à voir l'état
totalitaire sens
ce enfants sans forcément avoir des
sages ou quoi l'état totalitaire se
prépare déjà il est déjà en cours
on ad on a des éléments dans le mode de
tout selon actuels qui sont proches du
totalitarisme
les exemples
et pouvoir qu'on va donner au csa c'est
un très bon exemple
la liberté d'expression est une vertu
cardinale c'est un des éléments clés de
structures d'état démocratique on peut
pas avoir un système démocratique s'il
n'y a pas de liberté d'expression ce que
c'est de la liberté qui permet de
dénoncer tous les avions qui permet de
protéger toutes les autres libertés
à partir du moment où on donne le
pouvoir un organe administratif
de réguler et de la liberté d'expression
on commence ça c'est un pas vers la
sortie d'un modèle démocratique et d'un
état de droit
on retrouve exactement les mêmes mécano
sur par exemple les débats autour de
liberté d'expression dont la neutralité
du net la liberté d'expression étant un
volet à partir du moment où on autorise
les opérateurs à faire ce qu'ils veulent
sur le réseau en fait on les autorise à
modifier la société on les autorise à
modifier la façon dont les gens
interagissent entre eux et donc à avoir
à imprimer leur marque sur la société
qui vient avec c'est exactement ce que
fait apple avec apple store
l'app store de laïos c'est une façon de
déformer la société c'est la route
actifs non ça rend rendre captif
s'éteint c'est la méthode sais pas c'est
pas le problème
le problème c'est que quand tu pointu à
la mainmise de d'un organisme sur les
contenus disponibles tu as une morale
qui s'applique et tu as une vision du
monde qui s'applique et toute vision du
monde l'argent devient impossible
mais est ce que tu penses pas que le
mode opératoire traduit que font du
raisonnement non je pense que c'est le
contraire je pense que c'est parce qu'on
met en place ce type d'outil on a une
société qui basculent doucement vers une
espèce de total et d'autoritarisme soft
c'est vraiment je ne crois pas que c'est
parce que nous dirigeants ont des visées
totalitaire qui mettent en place des
outils de régimes totalitaires je pense
que c'est parce qu'on injecte dans le
régime des outils totalitaire que le
régime a un comportement de plus en plus
totalitaire est ce que tu peux est ce
que tu peux un petit peu nous je te
tutoie est ce que tu me fais un petit
peu nous développer le concept
d'internet à péage et de la dire la
neutralité du net les opérateurs veulent
faire quoi les conséquences en quelques
mots les conséquences de pouce à ce que
les opérateurs veulent faire c'est assez
simple
lecture à courte vue ils veulent
récupérer un tout petit peu d'argent de
plus que ce qu'ils récupèrent déjà en
fait sa part d'un constat qu qui est
enfantin un opérateur c'est quelqu'un
qui fait des travaux d'infrastructures
qui construit des réseaux qui a investi
des centaines de millions pour poser de
la fibre optique ou du cap
et
qui en échange de sa gagne 30 euros par
mois d'abonnement
un site de rencontre c'est un site web
qui fait presque rien qui fournit trois
pages et place de donner quelques
outil de recherche et qui vend ses
abonnements 30 euros par mois je pense
que c'est légitime le problème ce soit
légitime il y en a un des deux qui est
très jolie un journal et de jolies qui
s'est démené la toile pour gagner 2,30
euros l'autre café presque rien qui en
fait pour 30 euros de ventes et photos
parce que le seul contenu cas à vendre
le mythique de par exemple ce sont les
profils que les gens ont envie de subir
le seul truc que monsieur facebook à
vendre c'est ce que tu lui as donné la
nasa bricage ouvre une parenthèse
parlement un petit peu de ton donne moi
un petit peton boîtes de perception sur
le big data
c'est autre chose se gardent sous la
halle et je la vierge coudes pour tout à
l'heure leur
donc en fait la neutralité du net ce
sont les opérateurs qui cherchent à
récupérer une part de l'argent que ce
sont des gens qui développent les
services sur internet ils partent de
l'idée moi j'ai payé toute
l'infrastructure lui il a payé rien du
tout il sait autant argent moi et c'est
à juste et je sais pas si c'est juste ou
pas ce que je sais c'est que
c'est dangereux cercle est ce que en
fait comment ils veulent traiter ça ils
veulent faire en sorte de
cette situés écrit leur monde idéal tu
as pris un abonnement chez pinpin
télécoms et du coup tu as un un très bel
accès avait repeint vod est par contre
quand tu veux accéder à netflix hulu et
youtube s'élança marche pas bien et donc
du coup tous les films que tu achètes
sèche et papin vod tous les sites pornos
que tu regardes cse de pinpin bordeaux
etc etc etc et donc tout ce que tu
consommes tu achète des livres chez
tintin librairie surtout pas chez amazon
donc le modèle de business dans leur
modèle de business c'est de tenir dans
une bulle s'inverser et de de fabriquer
cette bulle fermé en faisant de la
priorisation sur le réseau que
ce qu'on défend nous c'est fait que en
faisant ça tue des formes le réseau est
une des formes la vision que les gens
ont du monde certes une a plus d'accès à
une information
de manière neutre vêtements quand tu es
sur le réseau internet de manière
normale tu vas voir n'importe quel site
web
tu te demandes jamais chez qui les
hébergeait tu te demandes jamais comment
il est raccordé au réseau tu as accès à
tout internet pas juste au bout que
l'opérateur a voulu contrer
il ya quinze ans il a essayé de faire
c'est que tu es portail captif il essaie
avec des portails t'arrivait sur le
portail orange vous savez les news la
météo machin est l'objectif était que tu
n'en sortent jamais qu'est ce que tu
penses qu est ce que ça va créer chez
les fenêtres des fournisseurs d'accès
associatif les fournisseurs d'accès
internet associative
mais en fait nous on est les moins mis
en danger là dessus parce que
nos abonnés ils ont accès à tous qu'ils
y ont accès comme ils veulent si ça
coûte cher en bande passante qui paye
cher en abonnement se pose pas de
questions très compliquées c'est nous on
est pas on n'est pas tellement la
question là dessus on est plutôt la
réponse mais plutôt la bonne réponse à
vos questions d'accord mais le fond du
problème c'est que tu des formes tu
défendes la perception que les gens du
monde
tu crées une société des formations en
fait tu revois créé un mécanisme aussi
pervers est aussi mauvais que la
télévision
certaines tares créé tf1 sauf que ça
s'appelle pas tf1 ça c'était laurent je
vois
[Musique]
télévision cette verdure
donc déjà pas un petit peu ton point de
vue sur la big data alors les questions
big data
bon il ya tout un tas de questions là
faisant qui sont extrêmement
intéressants pelé sont pas sur le sujet
qui sont les questions de business et
comment on peut faire du business et du
big data
il ya plein de gens qui les qui les
développent beaucoup mieux que moi et ce
sujet on ne passionne pas jeunes
entrepreneurs
ambition dans la vie n'est pas d'être
milliardaire doit me
de
le sujet pour moi c'est de comprendre à
quel moment ça te touche toi en tant
qu'humain et quel est le rôle que joue
l'utilisateur le corps
est ce que l'humain qui au milieu de
tout ça il est
juste la marchandise ils ferment bien sa
gueule
vous est-ce qu'il est quelque chose de
plus central crs qui reste avant tout
citoyen pensant actifs acteur de sa vie
autonome et à une et c'est en fait une
vraie question que tu peux déjà posés
sur des sites plus simple
je peux te l'a formulée de manière
enfantine qui est propriétaire de ce que
tu as vu sur facebook toi forcément toit
toutes les autres réponses sont
dangereuses toutes les autres réponses
disent que tu n'es plus adulte que
tu n'es pas libre de re lire tes
anciennes conversation peut être tu n'es
pas libre
de retirer les contenus que tu as mis
autre fois que tu n'es pas libre de
partir et donc pour moi il est un
élément central dans les questions sur
les données personnelles et sur le big
data qui et comment peut-on retenir
ça le lieu touristique a précisé dans
l'interview c'est curieux
agréable pour la russie
la question est de savoir en fait pour
moi ça revient quasiment à la question
de la portabilité des données c'est rien
système big data quel prix mais j'ai pas
de problème avec du moment que moi il un
acteur de ma vie je peux décider de
prendre mes billes partir ça peut être
effacé les données ça peut être juste
dire que je les emmène au star au point
d'un lieu touristique tu es ce que tu
penses que les gens qui viennent de
passer deux mois la population les
jeunes sont conscients de ces enjeux de
société ça vient ça vient ça hier
qu'elle soit enfin revenir
ça vient plus vite qu'on le croit il
devient par les gamins ça veut dire sur
les garages et comprennent très vite
écoute moi j'ai pas l'impression je te
donne un exemple très façon
le résultat de la chaire snowden c'est
que les gens ont compris ce que c'était
que les métadatas sur le téléphone
qu'ils comprennent que ça existait quand
tu leur parles et technique quand tu
leur en parler il ya trois ans et qui
n'étaient pas c'est quand tu leur dis
ton téléphone envoie sur le réseau d
intro de géolocalisation en permanence
ils comprennent pas évident que oui
d'abord les opérateurs enregistrent ça
en fait ils ignoraient pendant mon âge
et opérateurs à baisser certains
opérateurs dont des oeuvres des rapports
font sanguin avec ses services de
renseignements ou dessins toujours les
services de renseignement ont des
rapports contre guin avec les grandes
roues
soit
gouvernement est copain avec les patrons
du cac 40 c'est pas une grande nouveauté
fois très innovant c'était vrai ce
football situe le double f
orce à ceux des pillards ce qui convient
à la télévision donc mai
si tu veux pour moi la prochaine de ce
glacier 2 quelques exemples de très bête
sais tu devrais pouvoir sur facebook en
quelques clics télécharger un fichier
qui contient toute ta page facebook tout
pour ce que tu as dit ce que les gens
tombent dis ce que tu as fait ton
historique ton carnet d'adressés
contacts de tes copains un tout ce
qu'ils ont tu as dit avec le ca tous que
c'est ce book archi pompon mais c'est
possible non alors que tu peux pas
récupérer le cerf le seul mais qui a
réussi à le récupérer il s'est mangé des
années de procès pour y arriver et il a
le droit d'avoir de tous sous forme d'un
pdf c'est inutilisable je devrais
pouvoir récupérer tout ça sous un format
utilisable d'accord on a un autre
exemple ton opérateur de téléphonie à
les données de géolocalisation soit pour
mobiles sur le bout de sion qui te
donnes où il y met et factures il te
mets tes factures détaillées qui tu as
appelé combien de temps à parler avec
dame et meyer tout ça et de le mettre tu
peut même télécharger les messages
qu'elle sortait en boîte vocale pourquoi
un côté il n'ya pas les données qu'il
assure toi disant ben voilà ça c'est les
traces qu'on a de géolocalisation ya pas
de secret tu savais très bien où tu
étais
le même le savoir qu'ils ont les données
seraient de toi un acteur beaucoup plus
conscients de ce que tu es de ce que tu
fais de ce qu'il sait sur toi du fait
qu'ils petit peu donné ça la police sur
toi où il peut donner ça à quelqu'un
d'autre ou il peut-être un copain qui
travaillent c'est pour avoir deux galas
des thèmes la balle alors accès aux
informations d'accord donc ça te permet
de savoir ce qui existait à partir du
moment où tu 5,6 à créditer peut-être
non je t'assure en pratique le mec qui
roule sur l'ordinateur etc
ready de couach a commencé à 2 personnes
pour le pouvoir infini dans une boîte
l'actionnaire est à lannilis ces deux là
ils font ce qu'ils veulent heureusement
un peu sur les jeunes est ce que tu m'as
les jeunes de plus en plus comprennent
qu'ils laissent des traces comprennent à
peu près qu'elle fera s'il s est il
suffirait que tu mettes en fait si tu
leur laisses accès aux données qu'ils
ont généré lecture en c2 des portables
qui puisse les emmener les utiliser
ailleurs alors ils vont très bien
comprendre dans quel monde y sont ils
vont très bien comprendre ce qu'ils font
je pense qu'on verra même apparaître des
formes d'art perverse qui consiste à se
comporter de manière à avoir laissé une
trace qui serait joli
ça veut dire que tu es c'est super
rigolo frais comme idée sais tu te
promènes avec comme objectif que la
trace laissée par ton téléphone un
toxique selon terrasse un joli dessin
fasse
un parcours historique dans paris face à
face à décines s'est jointe à
désapprendre lampions
tas de trucs apparaissent à partir de ça
d'accord je voudrais poser notre petite
question concernant la jeunesse
est ce que tu penses que les jeunes
générations voix ce soir deux plus
jeunes que l'on côtoie
[Musique]
un enseignement suffisamment pertinent
sur la question du numérique depuis
l'école parce que depuis l'école on les
sensibilise correct en moi tu as tes
yeux à ces questions le nom et la
question est périphérique externe ou
alors la questure états d'amérique
c'est pas au numérique il faut les
sensibiliser c'est à la société du
réseau c'est à la société qui construit
ce que je dis souvent apprendre la
programmation gamin ouais autant qu'on
leur apprend l'électronique se pratique
c'est bien d'avoir une petite culture
générale de comprendre les bases de voir
à peu près ce que ça fait ne pas croire
à la magie autres comprendre que ça
existe mais c'est important
le grand apport d'internet c'est
qu'internet permet aux gens d'écrire
internet permet aux gens de s'exprimer
que crée oil créé pour la poche
artistique tout de suite mais non juste
écrire ce que tu en fait ce que tous le
thé crise auront surtout facebook ou ton
blogueurs ou twitter ou sur ta page que
théberge sur la machine à la maison
parce que tu es qui sera lu par
potentiellement n'importe qui sur
internet ça existait pas avant
ma mère quand elle écrivait elle
écrivait une lettre à quelqu'un c'était
le précise des cibles et elle n'a jamais
écrit dans la presse grecque en train de
décrire une société beaucoup plus
horizontale je suis en train de te
décrire une société dans laquelle les
gens s'expriment en public et ils sont
pas formés à ça l'est pour moi dans
l'enseignement centrale autour d'eux
numérique tout ça
c'est vraiment la partie
expliquée apprendre aux enfants à
s'exprimer en public ces à prendre
sur moi les questions ont internet c'est
à pour les profs de maths ou pour les
portes des sciences c'est pour réponse
de française pour l'épreuve de philo
il faut apprendre aux gamins n'ont pas à
lire et écrire comme les icônes rosaires
dix neuvième siècle mais à lire et
écrire pour être lu et écrivain public
écrire pour publier ses seins ça c'est
un enseignement très particulier du
numérique qu'est ce que tu penses que
les profs et collectivement avec sa vie
à une société qui est horizontale mais
ça la société présente elle également
s'ils font très bien tous évidente elle
répondait forme d'accord est ce que tu
penses que l'éducation nationale est ce
que tu as un message à faire passer à
l'éducation nationale est ce que tu as
déjà essayé de certains services de
l'éducation nationale dans ce sens
non moi je bosse très peu sur les
questions d'éducation parce qu'elles
sont compliquées parce qu'elle suppose
de connaître
en faites vous connaître les rouages
faut savoir qui allait parler je connais
pas du tout ce monde là le mec qui fait
ça très bien sûr si tu veux poser des
questions sur le l'éducation numérique
c'est michel guillou qui vous plante
c'est le mec qui veut qui connaît le
sujet qui s'esquissait qui
étudia rigole comme tout quelqu'un de
très bien je devrais commencer donc on
va passer aux préconisations
si tu avais un conseil immortel a laissé
sur la toile aux jeunes générations
allez peut-être des deux conseils
gardez d'internet et gardez l'oeil
ouvert on vraiment les deux les deux
éléments créés comment comment ça on
trouvera c'est facile c'est comme
toujours c'est tu repères qui a du
pouvoir et veulent accroître et les
conserver et lui faut le des foules
taper et la paix c'est vraiment way de
le taper avec une loi si ça suffit
d'accord ça suffit pas se sentir plus
gros
et c'est exactement comme
protéger la liberté d'expression c'est
empêcher qu'il y ait tous les journaux
aux mains de trois pouvoirs c'est
empêcher qu'il y ait tous les partis aux
mains de trois lobby c'est empêcher que
face et faire en sorte que je reste
ouvert et internet est un outil qui
permet d'ouvrir le jeu et donc protéger
internet pour ceux qui n'aiment pas les
réseaux pas le numérique numérique ça
sert à rien je veux bien que celui
bausch x était en train de me filmer
dans numérique la tumeur est filmé en
argentine c'était pareil si au lieu de
me filme et avait noté mes propos pour
les recopier sur un tapis et c'était
pareil savez la même valeur là ne traite
pas la même rapidité
ouais sur ce même pas sûr quand elle
écrivait à sa copine savez peut-être
sauvé la cheval non
ouais ça m'était peut-être une semaine à
cheval d'un autre côté le porno était
plus contenté plus condensée du coup
plus structurée du coup plus réfléchi
avec moins de blanc avec là c'est pas
pareil
tu ressors n'importe quel bouquin
du xviie siècle en matière de politique
c'est autrement plus dense que les verts
qui pondent aujourd'hui et c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont plus intelligents
c'est juste ils réfléchissent plus pour
écrire
est-ce que tu allais site a conseillé
pour s'informer est ce que tu as des
méthodes ce que tu as des choses comme
ça gesca recel
pour s'informer c'est assez compliqué si
on peut comprendre les combats
politiques
tu as des infos sur la quadrature ils
sont bien faites
pour essayer de comprendre le monde qui
vient il n'y a pas grand chose il ya
quelques sites qui diffusent des infos
est vraiment pas grand chose j'ai pas de
trucs systématique comme ça après tout
tu fais comment pour t'informer toi
was as he was ardoise à
g
j'ai quelques sites sur lesquels je
m'informe qu'on vraiment tu m'emmerdes
écrit que ça à faire
steam pc inpact numerama ou
mais en fait il se trouve que 99% de la
formation dont j'ai besoin mais
apportées par les gens
g j'ai choisi
très précisément qui je follow sur
twitter et je follow pas les gens qui
disent des trucs rigolos que font les
gens qui disent des trucs intéressants
donc je dois je ne veux suivre qu'une
centaine de personnes ce qui n'est pas
beaucoup
quand il ya une info qui m'intéressent
cirque et dans le panorama 2d des sujets
que j'essaye de couvrir au général
geslin sociaux twitter très vite je
m'informe beaucoup plus par les réseaux
que par un point central la gouvernance
d'internet à la gouvernance d'internet
ça c'est un sujet rigolo c'est bien
parce que ça veut rien dire
c'est un des problèmes bien tu parles de
gouvernance quant à un organisme
structuré et internet n'est pas un an
galipeau structurer un peu comme si tu
voulais vous verrez une flaque d'eau feu
tu peut au mieux essayer de la contenir
en fait la gouvernance d'internet on met
souvent des idées assez par compliqué au
pacs est inaccessible aux profanes
en gros tu as quelques organismes
américains qui sont chargés de gérer
deux ou trois autres aux critiques sur
internet distribué les noms de domaine
gérés les distributions les attributions
de l'adresse ip
gérer deux trois conneries dans ce bout
là
à l'heure actuelle le seul état qui a un
pied là dedans ce le gouvernement
américain par le département du commerce
qui a un pied dans le fonctionnement de
ces organismes là et on nous fait tout
un foin du fait qu' il faudrait que
d'autres que les états unis et un pied
là dedans tout ça c'est essentiellement
de la merde ça présente pas d'intérêt
saout eu beaucoup les diplomates parce
que ça leur donne un sujet vachement un
pas intéressant à discuter en anglais
dans des conférences internationales des
sports etc etc ça présente pas d'intérêt
majeur
en matière de gouvernance si on veut
essayer de calmer
l'omniprésence américaine
il ya essentiellement de problèmes
autour de ces sujets là et ça ça se
résume à ces deux problèmes l'un qui est
la gestion de noms de domaine et tout ça
c'est un pur problèmes de droits
sauf que le droit applicable en matière
de noms de domaine et le droit américain
si tu veux contester un nom de domaine
c'est toujours la justice américaine qui
en dernier ressort tranche pas parce que
les grandes entreprises qui gère les
noms de domaine racines le point comme
le point net etc sont des entreprises
américaines
et ça c'est un problème certes pays
accueille la vie américaine du droit qui
prévaut
est la bonne réponse à ça on la connaît
déjà les documents d je te recommande
d'aller regarder ce que fait louis
pouzin sur le sujet par exemple c'est
d'avoir plusieurs racines au système de
dns d'internet
ça forcera à ses racines à coopérer
entre elles et ça rendra le système
beaucoup plus résilient et beaucoup
moins centralisée et le deuxième
problème qui lui est plus vraiment
beaucoup plus géostratégique
c'est l'adressage de réseau
je sais pas si tu sais
internet tels que nous connaissons est
essentiellement adressée par la version
4 du coût de qualité avec 4 milliards
d'adressés et pas très haut niveau
il ya une v6 qui existe qui permet
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
doute que cette adresse mais qui est
vraiment très tôt qui précise au niveau
du coccyx a parlé de ses problèmes au
niveau de la
taille a pas de conflit entre kiev et
chat avec la v6
6 incompatibles l'un avec l'autre on
sait faire des pascal poublang bricoler
entre les deux b ce sont deux réseaux
relativement incompatibles il se trouve
qu'à l'heure actuelle la majorité des
équipements s'apprêter les deux
protocoles son front n'utilise que la
version v4
quels problèmes cela va poser sa en
termes de géopolitique
c'est un truc très simple il ya plus
assez d'adressés ipv4 il ya beaucoup de
la super v6 ça veut dire que de plus en
plus les axes les accès internet qui
vont être fournies sont fournis sur des
adresses ipv6 alors que les access
server resteront sur des adresses ipv4
ça veut dire qu'on aura créé à
l'internet asymétrique c'est un internet
où les serveurs sont par la main sont
pas raccordés de la même façon écrit
d'heure et ça c'est un problème c'est
d'autant plus un problème que un peu
plus de 50 % des adresses ip sont
américaines
les états unis consomment 50 % de la
ressource alors que ce sont 5 % de la
population ça aussi c'est un problème
et donc savent attendre d'abord un homme
abîmé internet en le rendant sur un
modèle beaucoup plus proches du
militaire où les clients et serveurs ne
sont pas sur un pied d'égalité
mais en plus à faire en sorte que la
concentration aux états unis des
serveurs soient accentuées et devienne
structurel
qualité soit plus juste un aléa de la
vie économique mais qu'elle soit dans
codée dans la structure du système et ça
c'est un gros gros gros problème donc
typiquement les pays qui se posent des
tas de questions sur la gouvernance
d'internet devraient réfléchir à ça
c'est pas très compliqué à traiter
techniquement c'est en gros il faut
inciter les opérateurs
d'un peu partout à tout basculer en ipv6
a que les abonnements les aussi les
serveurs les sites les accès et c
est en fait si tu veux pour moi c'est un
tandem entre typiquement ce qu'a fait le
parlement européen soit la neutralité du
net en forçant les opérateurs à rester
sur un sur un jeu ouvert et sur un
réseau ouvert si ce qui a été voté au
parlement européen finit par devenir
réellement un règlement applicable non à
la une première brique très intéressante
et la deuxième est d'avoir un incitatif
très fort a basculé tout en v6 pas que
les abonnements métouia le faire plus
vite
pour éviter la pénurie est en train de
se créer sur v4 est l'espèce d'économies
malsaine et nauséabonde eux
on vend et achète des adresses ip ce qui
n'a aucun sens
donc là il ya un enjeu de géopolitique
du réseau qui est extrêmement fort et tu
peux être certain que les derniers qui
nous jouerons pour compass kilt ou
investissent ce sont les américains
parce que ça leur fait perdre la haute
main qu'ils ont sur le réseau
on voit envoie le problème sur d'autres
domaines serez-vous prêt ça c'est un
élément quand on parle de gouvernance
d'internet faut pas se tirer sur la
nouille pour savoir qui va rejoindre le
board de l'icann à part à la place du
department of commerce est ce que c'est
nonu est ce que c'est l'unesco est-ce
que c'est l agence internationale de
genève est ce que ça on s'en fout c'est
pas ça le sujet ça ça n'a pas
d'importance vous le regardez ça occupe
les diplomates qu'il faut leur laisser
un anneau s'arranger le vrai sujet il
est pas là le vrai sujet il est
technique il le vrai sujet technique
c'est comment on fait pour forcer le
réseau à rester ouverts je te passe du
coq à l'âne d'accord c'est ta phrase en
disant c'est comme essayer de découvrir
une flaque d'eau au mieux oignons peu
implanté à l'arrêt ça vaut mieux on peut
essayer de la contenir voilà au moins 2
et diablo surtout pas la critique est ce
que tu penses ça que la loi de
programmation militaire
tout l'arsenal législatif déposé cette
façon d'essayer dé contenir la fac
d'août sera sans reprendre le le mobile
à mediapart à booster le don et la
psychologie des foules est ce que tu
penses que la psychologie des foules à
porter un sac d'os que l'arsenal
législatif c'est pas une façon de
contenir le top de sa façon d'accéder à
la connaissance
l'article
de la loi de programmation militaire
c'est en fait une façon de permettre ça
c'est un outil dont se dote de pouvoirs
exécutifs pour surveiller et contrôler
la population c'est très clairement du
contrôle social
c'est pas pour traquer les terroristes
c'est pas pour traquer les méchants pied
de nazis ça ça se fait dans le code
pénal
quand on le fait dans la loi de
programmation militaire pour les
services de renseignement c'est à dire
pour les bars 12 et qu'on donne en gros
les pleins pouvoirs en matière de
surveillance au bar blues c'est qu'on
essaye de faire une petite est née sa à
la française alors nous on fait sa façon
pieds nickelés parce qu'on n'a pas les
budgets mais le but est clairement que
une forme de police
qui est secrète ces deux rois fait part
d'être puisse surveiller ce que fait la
population en permanence
avec un certain nombre de desks à l'état
de droit est ce concept inquiète quand
tu vois que
l'europe est en train de basculer dans
des gouvernements beaucoup plus instable
que des genres qui veillent au strict
des logements un petit peu ce qui
demande des réponses qu'est ce que ça
t'a inquiète de ce type de violence
légitime de tout parent d'état
arrivent
quand même à passer surtout que la façon
dont ça a été passé sur sam inquiète
évidemment de ça m'inquiète là mais je
ne vois pas de corrélation immédiat
contre des deux circuits
les politiques qui sont essentiellement
aujourd'hui les tenants de l'ancien
monde
aimerait que rien ne bouge parce qu'ils
veulent rester en haut de la pyramide et
s'est même pas forcément confiant mais
du coup ils font les lois dans ce sens
là donc ils font des lois visant à
contrôler la population parce qu'il
semble que la population ça gîte qui
font des lois visant à empêcher internet
de déborder parce qu'ils ne comprennent
rien à internet
c'est pas avec des visées totalitaire je
suis pas sûr que ce soit tout à fait lié
à la montée des totalitarismes la montée
des totalitarismes
en europe elle est flagrante et elle est
plutôt lié à des questions de
macroéconomie
certes on retrouve les mêmes limites et
de totalitarisme dans l'europe des
années 30 pour des raisons similaires
qui sont la répartition des richesses
produits qui sont les structures
économiques et qui sont pas pour faire
simple pour la finance envoie en l'air
cinq ans plus tard le fascisme ventes en
europe c'est comme ça la finance est
envoyé en l'air environnant 2008 le
fascisme et entre animateurs en europe
c'est comme ça
pour les mêmes raisons qu'en 1929 d'un
appareil apple n'y a pas de changement
profond
à l'époque ça prenait le salsa prenait
des formes très particulières en europe
le même problème c'est le même délire du
capitalisme où on voit les revenus du
capital et donc le prix du capital
augmenter les revenus du travail paie
c'est la répartition de richesses se
faire de travers donc
en gros tu cherches ce que détiennent
des 10% les plus riches d'un pays versus
ce que détiennent les 50 % les plus
pauvres et puis l'écart augmente plus il
ya une tension dans la société et cette
tension se résout toujours par le fait
que les puissants qui sont à ses voisins
des riches
envie qu'eux
mais jose reste stable que le monde ne
change pas et donc font tout pour
empêcher le monde de changer et créé une
tension avec la tension sociale devient
une tension politique
ça con d'éric vers des systèmes
totalitaires et on voit plusieurs
briques en ce moment whittall csa qui
est une brique whitta la loi de
programmation militaire qui est une
brique tattoo le mode de régulation de
la finance par la contrainte sur ce
qu'on est en train de faire la grèce
conneries voilà tout ça se tient
le fait que les safiots vont arriver au
pouvoir c'est pas une conséquence
internet et c'est pas une conséquence de
loi de programmation militaire c'est les
deux sont les conséquences du même
phénomène de société qui va mal
d'ailleurs merci
ou tout ça repose sur le principe de
confiance dans les systèmes et le
principe de juste réciprocité mais c'est
évident que
on peut avoir des glissements très
important c'est à dire qui est plus
réciprocité on a des pannes à des
patients et à dos les couleurs c'est ça
le problème c'est plus de service qui va
se brancher sur la ligne et qui va
écouter ce qu'ils puissent qui se passe
qui va même intercepté ce qui se passe
leiria l'air pinot simple flic est
terminée voilà dans le recueil de
données s'il y a un doute il n'ya pas de
doute c'est à dire que chaque fois qu'un
trader chaque fois qu'un directeur
chaque rencontre et est pratiquée dès
des
décisions contraires à l'éthique de base
d'une maison ils étaient renvoyés
[Musique]